[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for day number four of the 2019
st. Louis norm Congress I'm Ben Simon
back here again with Grandmaster in
residence
Alexander Linderman Alex a lot of the
games are breaking down so let's not
waste any time we'll get to the
standings after five rounds in our
Grandmaster norm section in the
Grandmaster norm section two players
stand atop of the field and they're both
gate keepers the grandmasters they have
nothing to gain except the prize money
they are keeping everybody down that is
the goal of the grandmasters here they
are the gatekeepers but we have some
strong contenders in this field
including Joel Piniella and Andrew Hong
and branded Jacobsen and then we have a
few other names in there as well just in
Wang and Tata of Abraham Ian who is
surprising us very pleasantly in this
event and Brian Escalante and Casa
Corley bringing up the rear of this
division and let's take a look at our
standings in our I am norm section where
our gate keeper Luis Torres is at the
top along with Aaron Jacobsen who he's
playing today or he just was and Keaton
Kyra as well now if you're just joining
us for the first time you may be
wondering what a norm is and we'd like
to tell you right now a norm you need
three of them their performances
quantifiably good performances in
tournaments where at least three other
players already hold the title being
sauce so we have three grandmasters in
the top section three international
masters in the second section and you've
got a score really well six and a half
in most cases to get a norm and all of
the players have different amounts of
norms to their name one two three in
some cases they have all three but you
also need to get a rating threshold so
we're going to cross those paths up here
when we get to them and we have very
diverse fields in in the sections as
well at least four have to be
represented we have 6 and 5 respectively
respectively and let's take a look at
our tournament format
we're dealing with 210 player around
Robyn's time control 90 minutes with a
30-second increment there is no second
time control the players have to keep
notation for the entire event because of
that 30-second increment our tournament
schedule it gets a little bit simpler
from here on out this is our last double
day and tomorrow and Tuesday we will
have one round each simpler to follow
slow down the pace to our grand finale
which could include playoffs on Tuesday
and that's at 4 p.m. if we need them and
we might ok we invite you to join us all
across social media on YouTube I have
the chat open right now some people like
chess some people don't but at least
they're watching so that's good hashtag
norm Congress okay here are the pairings
for our grandmaster norm section in
round number 6 casa Corley vs. Brandon
Jacobson Jackson Pouliot vs. Bryant
Escalante JJ a lemur on D vs. Tata
Abraham Yin Justin Wang versus joel bana
WA Dennis Boros vs. Andrew Hong I think
out at least five the key matchup the
one that's really interesting going on
right now
is JJ versus Tata let's see this game
Alex what is your analysis so far of
what's happening oh this was again a
very sharp game and on so far TTFN has
you know making oh alright well we just
lost our connection let's get a look at
the board here if we can of the of Tata
vs JJ man technical problems just rear
their heads at the worst times don't
they docto has really been surprising us
very pleasantly this event she came in
as the bottom seed and she has w GM I'm
sorry I am norm possibilities as well
but she already has all of our IM norms
she has has to cross a 2400 rating
threshold and right now she's sitting at
a published rating of 23 73 so Alex even
though we're not going to be looking at
the board as of yet tell me what you see
in this position on the board we have
our live table yeah well this is this
position is very sharp I mean the ITF
has sacrificed
peace for a few poems earlier in the
game and it looked like she had very
good initiative actually a very good
position but now it's probably not as
clear because white looks like found
some defensive resources and I would say
that the game is still very sharp it can
go either way the time is also quite
level maybe instead of Queen t3 there
was also 93 bringing the knight back
into defense but you know of course
we'll be able to analyze the game deeper
when we when our technical issues will
stabilize right right so well we'll come
back to this game shortly but let's go
to our next division the International
master norm section where two games have
actually already finished so let's take
a look at the pairings for round six in
this division we know that Ezra chambers
has just defeated Rochelle Wu and right
before we took the air
Louise Torres defeated Aaron Jacobsen
and that was a game that I thought was a
real key matchup unfortunately we can't
take a look at it yet because of our
tech issues but we will a little bit
later on now it's important to note this
was such an important game for Aaron
Jacobsen who's tie in Louise Torres in
the lead along with Keaton Kiera
Jacobsen stands at three and a half you
need six and a half to get an IM norm
and he already has one he's fighting for
his second in this event now it's
looking really really dodgy for him
because with three rounds left he would
need a perfect three a no score to get
that norm yeah it's still possible
though I mean I've seen that happen
before and certainly I know Aaron pretty
well he's a very good fighting player
know today you know he got outplayed you
know Torres played a very nice attack
but now he got Taurus who was in great
form out of the way and hopefully he'll
be able to feast on some players for
maybe not in as good of a form and I
think there's always a chance as long as
there's a mathematical chance so I still
believe in him and we'll see what
happens right okay it's
so now let's take a look at our prize
funds what these players are competing
for it's not too shabby for a normed
tournament $9,000 is the total fund for
the a group the champ walks away with
$2,000 and no one goes home empty-handed
not too bad as well for the I M group
$6,000 on the line and our champion in
the I M group the B group will leave
with $1,200 himself so while we are
having these tech issues we may need to
bow out for just a moment as Jim Ross
says hey we're live pal so you never
know what's gonna happen but thanks for
joining us we should be back here in
just a moment and with the digital board
right back and darn it it was working
just before we took the air so how about
that yeah well it was perfect you know
the previous two days no problems
alright whatsoever but somehow ever
since I came here I've been tested with
technical problems all the time it's
like almost like my nervous system has
been tested because I've been running
into technical problems all the time
ever since I came so maybe it's me
bringing bad luck or whatever but we
shall prevail we shall prevail Alex yeah
we shall prevail
so let's bow out for just a moment and
we'll be back don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
you
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major error
instead
boogie through the city and discover the
music that gave the Blues their name at
the National Blues Museum Broadway
Oyster Bar or even the legendary
Blueberry Hill so whether you love the
Cardinals the Blues or the Blues come
play with us you guys know I can't play
this right st. Loup is always exploring
everybody welcome back crisis averted
Ben Simon here with Grandmaster Alex
Linderman now let's get to our
Grandmaster norm key matchup tots of
Abraham E and his black versus JJ a
lemur on D let's take a look yes so once
again just like against Brandon you know
2tf is playing the French you know her
her bread and butter you know which
she's a very big expert on and once
again we know we're getting a very nice
fighting game Queen you - the idea is to
go rogue d1 and try to capture with the
night and then maybe with the rook and
get a lot of pieces in the game I
remember I've laid this line a few times
so black and I remember this this was
like one of the problematic lines for
block so 97 takes takes and Queen c7
typical set up for block normally as far
as I've analyzed black is usually okay
as long as she can get this set up with
the bishop on d6 Queen and c7 and a
knight on e7 and one of the main reasons
for playing Queen d7 instead of Queen g6
by the way is that after Queen d6
castles there's you have to play Knight
f6 because if you go knight c6 94
followed by Queen e2 Andrew T 1 is
considered to be an unpleasant
initiative for black so when you go
Queen d7 though castles knight c6 you
can go knight c6 because 94 does not
come with a temple and after Knight b3
you can now play a setup where you put
the bishop on d6 and I'll study have
played put the Queen on c7 as well and
now I leave moranga started playing very
ambitious the Bishop e5 check very
interesting double edged move
rising apiece but the point being that
after the TF accepts Knights XB v double
attacks the queen and the bishop but of
course this is not the end of the story
because black takes an h2 with a check
if you didn't have this if she didn't
have this move of course it's losing for
black but black saw it all in advance 25
and now a very nice idea
g3 I'm wondering if this was still
preparation by a limb around or whether
this was over the board inspiration but
the idea being a very brilliant Queen
sacrifice if Queen takes it sue how does
white win here you can pause quickly if
you want to find it 97 King f8 rogue g8
check beautiful checkmate so black is
forced to take on g3 takes now the queen
is protected conveniently by the bishop
takes takes and now white once again
plays a very nice queen it's a disparado
queen you know if you take once again
there's the mating idea so black goes 25
96 King f8 so you see how white
sacrificed a couple of points but now
White has a very very much a lot of
initiative for its forest pawn but the
question is whether this really was
enough maybe objectively the best move
was to go Queen e2 and this could have
actually resulted in a very fun draw
Queen g3 Quinn g4 and you just you know
dealing with a disparado Queen and have
black plays a move like Queen b8 you
will lose two lines that Queen takes
root g8 Quincy 3 with too many threats
countless threats so anyway in the game
White was playing for the win naturally
he's GM higher rated player but now 2 TF
played a wonderful move h5 counter
attacking the Queen and making the Queen
go off his very nice post on g4 queen g3
and another nice move it for Queen f2
Queen h5 94/95 c4 and this looks like at
least maybe this is a mistake maybe a
move like Ruchi one was better trying to
go to g5 after C 4 black found a great
move here once again
counter-attacking Queen a5 and
wondering whether white might have
missed this move because after check
King g8 Queen e2 Bishop d7 another very
nice move
very nice piece sacrifice suddenly Black
has tons of initiative in this position
takes takes maybe actually Bishop d7 was
the move that was missed because maybe
Ally Miranda was thinking Knight of 6
and then you could take take and some
bishops e7 with some initiative still
black might be doing well here but after
this 96-95 Bishop c6 black is already
you know very much in control with very
good development three points for the
piece and very nice initiative in fact
there might have been even been better
ways for blacks to play here like this
should be five Queen takes b5 Queen h3
King h1 and a very nice fruit left rogue
h6 but you know the way that she have
played is very natural human way
but this allowed white so at least block
the diagonal and the bishop is kind of
not doing as much here and after this
Queen of one Queen c2 couple of more
moves have been played and here was
where Ally Miranda made a very huge
mistake in this position a wide
absolutely had to bring that night back
into the into the defense by going 93
trying to play move like rook c1 and
trying to kind of restrict the black
Queen a little bit but instead of that
and here the game would still be an
unclear anyone's game instead Queen t3
was played allowing queen of two and
suddenly black with perfect play has a
decisive initiative rook g1 rook f1 was
played rookie one very strong moved the
removing White's main defender takes
takes king edge 2 and now we're here in
this position where if black plays the
move rook h6 black is actually having
the decisive attack because he attack
she attacks the bishop and also once the
player she's 6 followed by moves like
Queen g1 and black is actually
completely winning this position if
black plays this position correctly
black is completely winning in this game
so this boy would that be a huge result
for that
chef's if she manages to upset with
block a lemur Andi absolutely and it's
it's interesting because this position
it to just a immediate glance it doesn't
look like black is totally winning but
looks are deceiving here thank you for
that explanation there's a lot going on
though let's jump over to Group B we
have Keaton Kira versus Gauri Shankar
and it looks like Kira is is looking
pretty good in this event one of the
gatekeepers one of the three
international masters is Kira yeah he
absolutely is in this position why does
look at the time difference yet he ever
has Keaton has 21 minutes and Diary is
playing literally living off of the
increment in fact he has 31 seconds that
means he made his last move with one
second left he came this close to
flagging but of course it's not even the
time that's the main concern for black
it's the position white is up here 1 2 3
4 5 white is up a pawn but look at this
extra point and she 6 completely
restricting the blacks King black the
black Queen is basically paralyzed to
defend the guns all these difficult
threats black is basically holding on
his last legs and white can play move
like a four or even bush 63 might work
where in all these lines white is
actually having the decisive advantage
so let's see how this happened the line
actually was here very interesting night
of 3 g5 e3 this was first made popular
when Sergey kuryakin that year when he
won the candidates and qualified to play
Magnus Carlsen in 2016 he won a very
important game in round 4 against BC
Anand with this line and I'd have 3 to 5
III the point being is white sometimes
wants to play line with c4 but then
there is d4 gaining space which leads to
unclear game so white therefore plays e3
preparing for c4 and kind of getting a
very interesting sharp kind of an
attacking position b3 Bishop d6 Bishop
d2 castles and this is a line I've
played myself with white quite a few
times I've usually played the move
Knight c3 here and then you know there
are lines like c5 and even moves like g4
h for ideas in this position
but in the game mr. B 2 was played 97
maybe it was also good to play b6 and or
and or c5 here but in any event this is
a very sharp position requires deep
analysis Queen c2 c5 all logical Knight
c3 b6 and now white went for it
g4 and like I said in this line a white
usually needs to play very ambitiously
because black controls the center pretty
nicely and if y doesn't do anything
black will be very comfortable so white
plays a very sharp way g4 this should be
7 g5 going for some kingside expansion
98 Orochi 1 and in this position I would
say black should be fine here but he has
to play very precisely and here I don't
like his move Knight c7 which i think is
moving the night away from the defensive
from the kingside defense I think I move
like rook c8 it would make a little more
sense trying to go Bishop e7 and then
96-95
trying to blunt the talk a little bit
also maybe there should be seven right
away would deserve attention let's say
after h4 sorry about that
h4 I move like 96 and once again the
knight would come to a5 and maybe black
would be more comfortable but of course
the position still looks insane this
sharp but after Knight C 7h for b5 yeah
black decided to sacrifice a pawn here
but it seems like white can just get
away with taking the pawn and black
doesn't really have all that much
compensation why because as I have
realized one sacrifices positional porn
sacrifices or in general positional
sacrifices rarely work unless your
pieces are of better quality than your
opponent's and in this position white
has all very good pieces so there's very
little grounds based on why this kind of
thing should work and even though white
has a good center it doesn't hurt
I mean black has a good center it
doesn't hurt black because Knights
coming over to H four or five and
basically white is very much in control
from this point on and why just White's
attack just goes flows very natural
sure a block and block it but now this
pawn on g6 becomes a monster
and as we've seen you know white you
know was very much in control from here
maybe white could have played more
precisely but white see it seemed like
white was always very much in control
and eventually was able to get the job
done black went for some last-minute
counterplay but it never really came
into fruition and and now we're you know
they're a couple of removes been made
King C to Bishop f6 Bishop takes c3 okay
why just simply took a very important
one now and yeah the rest is matter very
simple technique up to pawns and no real
counter play for black you know it's
safe to assume that white will unless a
miracle happens white will win this game
good stuff from 31 year-old Keaton Kiera
out of San Diego Gauri Shankar tough day
for him but remember there's still an
evening round later on tonight yeah and
unfortunately this will be very caustic
for a guy you worried if he wins if he
loses this game he will be pretty much
out of the north attention yeah although
I think he has all the norms I think he
needs the ratings so still very much a
lot to play for so but very big win
would be for Keaton because he's now
currently in the lead and he would
basically stabilize his leading position
and he would be joining tours with four
and a half out of six again the
gatekeepers are making it very tough on
the norm seekers in this tournament
absolutely they are I would like to see
Danish boys vs. Andrew Hong and on top
division and because if we get to the
point where there's no norm
possibilities and this is a closed
tournament so it's it's pretty likely we
won't we're gonna be looking at who's
gonna be in first and Boros is one of
those contenders yeah and in this
position the white is absolutely
completely winning white is up a whole
queen for just a rope plus there is not
even a sign of any kind of fortress here
in fact after white moves the kings who
have two or three I mean white blocks
pieces are dis coordinated and at any
moment
black can either get made it or lose
more material so this is a completely
winning position for white and Plus you
know
has more than enough time to think
through and work it out black in the
meantime is playing love of the
increment so clearly this game has gone
Boris's way so let's quickly see what
happened here
the opening was a reasonably fashionable
a4 line against an eider
which I'm not a big expert on because I
don't play this from either side but I
know that this has been recently
popularized and this is kind of a
positional line trying to fight for the
d5 square and here is maybe interesting
to go for a line like take stakes and
then 75 come very concrete play maybe
sacrificing some material taking
advantage of the fact that the rookin
aides who is a little bit misplaced but
after knight c6 castles rook c8
ruby one Queen c7 Bishop g5 it looks
like white positional is getting what he
wants he's gonna be able to trade off
the bishop for the night and get control
over the d5 square and as long as wife
controls the d5 square without black
getting counter play white will just be
better so black played a good move
Knight before fighting for the square of
course white will never want to take on
e6 here because that would completely
abandon control over the d5 square and
would open the file on their file the
double points would not be worth it so
white played Bishop III rook to e8 and
now white played 91 with the idea of
trying to improve the night maybe a5 was
also possible here but he played 91
mister g4 and this move is very
interesting the idea of it being trying
to disturb White's harmony trying to
induce the move of three and then maybe
trying to you know take advantage of
some dark squares later in the game this
was an interesting idea knowing that the
pawns don't go backwards
hashtag Sam Franklin's recent very good
book on that theme you know you can also
watch some YouTube videos on on that
she's you know done some very good
lectures on that so King H 1 may be 93
was also possible King H one night e8
and Bishop goes back to e3 so I'm
wondering if 98 was really the best move
or maybe a move like room d7 might have
been better just keeping the tension so
98 bishop
three white doesn't want to take here
because after after this the night gets
closer to c7 where it controls d5 so
that's why white plays Bishop III
keeping blocks pieces a little bit
uncoordinated and now black decided to
go for it
for this d5 idea that we've mentioned
before but possibly what black missed
here was he was probably thinking white
will take and then Queen a5 getting
counter play the pawn on d5 maybe Knight
of 6 and black being completely fine but
maybe he missed the intermediate move
rook a c1 after which the Queen has to
go to if Queen goes to a5 let's say then
we take this first and after this white
takes with the rook now and now there's
no more compensation in this position
because the pawn on d5 is not weakened
white is the south lay of a pawn
so black ended up actually getting
really caught off guard I mean maybe it
was still fine so go Queen b8 and take
with the Queen and after edie play a
move like a little Knight of 6 or Queen
c7 and maybe black is a bit worse but it
should still be some compensation but
instead Andrew decided to really go for
drastic measures here with Knight 63 and
now after this basically white is just
up a queen and even though you know it
looks like black has some counter play
it's not nearly enough and even though
there's Bishop before there's always
Queen c8 basically and ever since why
just consolidated and well I'm not sure
if f4 was the best move though maybe
here there may be worth some
inaccuracies
because for example after this takes it
takes there was maybe some idea like 93
which maybe it was a chance for black
actually so get back in the game but
black played c6 Knight of three takes
takes rook c2 King III and yeah it looks
like it was a sharp game still mistakes
on both sides but the last mistake looks
like was here if you pardon me with meit
looming here you might want to keep your
eye on Andrew
who looks pretty despondent they're at
the board and it's over yes Dennis
burrows with the victory with white and
Andrew Hong mathematically unable to
norm in this event but he's had not a
bad tournament that so far I mean
starting off pretty strong but now I
think broche is maybe the one of the
ones to watch as far as getting first
place in this event but there are still
norms to be had we can finish out the
game if you'd like Alan yes so I mean
here it looks like let's say if black
plays a move like b6 then e6 would still
mean be not so scared because after
takes takes takes takes King g7 okay you
can lose the spawn but after row gauge
five actually black still is very much
within drawing boundaries black in fact
this is just a fortress how is white
ever gonna break through here cannot
make a passport cannot get the rope over
five so this will be a def draw if white
goes free six but black made a blunder
here played rugby - and unfortunately
now after e6 takes takes you know if
you're gonna take on e6 now you're just
gonna lose the rook on b2 and if King h8
Queen f6 Bishop g7 and we get made it
with Quincy eight so it looks like black
and time pressure made a very big
blunder allowing me six at a very wrong
moment and even after Rotex b3 King e2
there is still no way to take on e6
because queen takes c6 will pick up the
row can't be too so unfortunately for
Andrew
he is just completely losing and now he
tried to play on here but of course
there's no realistic chance anymore and
and this was the final position you know
there are a couple or more moves played
but of course white is now threatening
mates
several different ways and here black
had nothing left to do but to resign
yeah those checks won't last forever
let's jump back over to our b group and
look at a game Erin Griffin ski versus
Eric Rosen we haven't seen that one yet
and it looks like grab in skis gonna get
a big win here over a man
very familiar within Rosen yeah very big
win for guru bin ski because he's been
really having a very rough tournament
unfortunately for him I mean he just
needs to get that rating up but
unfortunately this tournament
it'll he'll have to at least try to get
out of this tournament with minor losses
and hope to come back in in another
tournament that's what he's fighting for
is right but you know he played an an
interesting opening here e4 c5 Knight
a36 b3 a little bit of a sideline and
even went for some Bishop d3 and managed
to confuse Eric a little bit well at
first I think black was doing fine
but maybe it was better to just castle
or something I'm not sure about allowing
t4 you know in the best possible
scenario and 25 so here at Leeds white
got the unbalanced position he wanted
and here to maybe Bishop e5 would have
been a better option but he played there
g3 a6 and yeah it's a sharp game it's
hard to critic focus here in every
single critical moment but basically
yeah this night c2 was very nice
trying to go 93 and not capturing back
right away and here it looks like white
is ready in control and white is about
to take back on d5 with a very pleasant
advantage thanks to the control over the
d5 square so black decided to go for an
unbalanced game but from this point on
it was kind of all white because white
has still control over than t5 then he
won the porns then he traded Queens
methodically and I know Erin is a very
good technical players so I figured this
kind of position he will probably not
let go of and and indeed he played in a
very nice technical matter just shutting
down every possible counter play and now
white is a popcorn with a better quality
rook better King and usually as I've
been always realizing as as I've been
told a few times by people that if
you're up opponent in the rook and Game+
with a more active rope usually it's
it's completely
for the defending site and indeed Alex
while you take a look at how this game
is petering out we do have Danish
burrows ready for an interview so I will
be back in just a bit
sounds good so once again before we get
down is worse let's quickly take a look
again and touch TF scheme and that saves
game black is now completely winning
black was able to recover the piece we
last off where white played this huge
mistake Queens III lock up chance to go
here and trade the rooks and now black
bedrock h6 and suddenly turns out that
you know because of all these made
threats
White had to sacrifice the piece back so
now blacks simply recover the piece that
she sacrificed and now black is just
simply up three pawns in an endgame and
white is still playing this out hoping
for a miracle but of course at this
point I have almost no doubt that black
will be able to convert this and this
would mean that that CF still has a
chance and in fact as I as I was as well
as I was speaking that CF just
sufficiently officially won wide
officially resigned the game and the now
touch F is back at A+ score and
continues to play very good and
enterprising chess a very nice win
against one of the top seeds in the
tournament JJ so with that said we now
have Dennis Morris with us Dennis very
nice game today yeah we're still very
topsy-turvy I yeah I was very tense yeah
but you prevailed an end so what do you
think were the main critical moments in
the game I thought that it seemed to me
that this remover of a c1 was probably
missed by your opponent right could
possibly I I wasn't sure about d5 his
sacrifice although I think it's very
principled in fact he took on b3 but if
he goes back to nine up six then could
be okay as well yeah knight of six could
also be fine yeah
oh there may be a five and I
have some pressure night of 685 yeah
there was also possibility of maybe a
few moments ago maybe here playing a 5
did you consider that I don't know how
good that is but I did not because I
wasn't sure if that pawn won't become a
weakness mhm
like let's say 8 6 yeah age 6 and then
maybe you can try to play for this idea
and the bishop on BC but yeah I don't
know if that's good actually he calls
rookie 8 yeah they say 5 is yeah it's
not so clear no no if 5 is like double
edged like double-edged yes so you
played 91 which looks logical here black
should be fine and now this Bishop c4 is
a very interesting move trying to yeah
it was a good King edge 198 yeah and
here 98 I'm not sure if it was necessary
but it was probably okay Bishop e3 and
yeah block maybe could just go back back
yeah although now I could really try a 5
because my bishop is supporting mm-hmm
and then maybe I have some pressure so I
mean it made sense for him to go for d5
mm-hmm yes yeah takes 95 I even
considered taking with the pawn and rook
c1 but maybe Queenie 525 here yeah yes
and I can even get worse so that's why I
decided that I should go nicely so
there's some Bishop g1 maybe a touchy
one but in any event it's not so clear
here but no of course if you see the key
move rook c1 then it makes sense to take
what the night yeah but then what were
you gonna play if let's say queen bee it
was wanted to take on c8 Queen takes and
into a takes yeah and then this position
I'm guessing black has compensation
maybe not quite enough but it should
still be something yeah this is 7 over
96 mm-hmm actually I was looking for
Queen f5 but maybe that's a little
inaccurate Quinn a5 here right yeah
queen of five might also be possible but
then she I can try to reposition the
bishop here and attack this one in any
event Knight 63 was played I mean yeah
it was quite definitely very
shot in some ways because I felt that
this
be fine for white but I'm not sure now
like there's definitely lots of play no
it was maybe more interesting than you
know it looks here and certainly there's
some compensation
yeah I was thinking Queen C 3 I was
wondering about Queen e2 as well but I
felt that Queen C 3 is more precise
because I'm always reading these greens
CH x yeah because if Queen e2 then okay
I wanna hear you're still a bit tied
down you still have to eventually
control them before school hears Bishop
g5 ideas yes like that and it's very
tough to move yes
so in the position now Queen c3 was good
a5 g3 in 96
King G to Bishop here Queen is here and
looks like why it's supposed to be
consolidating there but of course
there's still practical difficulties
here
Roxy one so what were your thought
processes when you decided to play for
f4 here and f4 I looked at all kind of
tricks for him but after I checked it I
felt that everything's fine mm-hmm but
then f4 as Andrew pointed out there's 93
yeah that's that's that's that was
possible right so maybe I move like
Queen b8 yeah because that's what Andrew
said yeah because what what can blog to
hear if f6 then you can try Queen d8 and
attack the spawn and it looks like
ending of six would be very yeah so it
looks like white should probably play it
more slowly
but if four was a very ambitious move of
course it's a very risky move to play
because even if everything works longer
in the long run they're still gonna be
all these things hanging right now so in
the game g6 was played but yes as Andrew
pointed out this would have probably
been a yeah well it's probably unclear
but it's still unclear because the
Knights misplaced by v6 but maybe black
you know is yeah the back is not risking
marching can play for every result but a
46 and even after this it looks like
there were some chances for black
interesting because here I felt that I
consolidated after
I put mine on f3 yes so I thought until
black you know made the blunder missing
6 yeah I thought and so until this move
it wasn't so easy like for example if
black plays a simple move like b6 mm-hmm
it's still not so easy right what is the
right play can I go for f5 and try to
push probably a 5 is your best try and
then let's say rook h3 check King f2
king of two yet she takes a 5 and then
we try to put an IV 6 position so
probably black yeah I mean that f5 is
probably at this point the best because
if you actually play h 6e 6 here then
it's completely
yeah the rook is defending our age -
yeah does this kind of thing you know
you can never win because yeah this trip
just comes fear or look on h5 and it's
CF fortress in it and maybe even black
and dream a little bit yeah maybe a
little but of course it's it should be
about that wrong but yeah rugby -
unfortunate was very costly put the rook
on a very about square and after he six
then that's that was then the game
basically because I have this fine trick
Indian Knight takes if Knight takes yeah
that's what I was showing the copper
King h8 and I've checked on 85 actually
I thought the same thing yeah and then
Queen yeah so very big win for you
Dennis congratulations on you know very
tough grinded out win you know looking
for chances in the very end and how do
you feel going into the last three games
now
not so sure mmm this was a very tense
game I felt I made some I wouldn't even
say small mistakes and I feel that I
guess I need to be careful even though
everything seems to work out fine I was
in trouble against Justin here this got
very messy I'd say so far so good but so
in other words a good advice to
everybody even when we're doing well we
should not rest on our laurels and we
have to always you know be careful
because chess could always be a humbling
game but let's hope that in this
tournament
the game doesn't humble you and let's
hope this tournament continues going
very well for you I just wanted to
mention that I've been streaming the
couple of days with alienage Nick and
now he's doing a stream substituting and
by the way to those of you who don't
know Italy emission occurs a very strong
Grandmaster 2650 plus fee they probably
top 100 was one world open at least a
few times the Webster student definitely
a big name in us in in the u.s. chess
so he's dreaming on chess leap and
actually had a big result like he came
second behind cause in the bullets
tournament Wow I do know that pretty
impressive very impressive so I would
advise you to tune in if he's still
online yeah thank you very much Dennis
for for coming here and I wish you best
of luck and best of skill in the last
three rounds
thank you alright so with that said do
we have the center one to come whole
sore okay so with that said let's go
back to the game with between Justin
Wengen and Joel banaba we haven't taken
a look at that just yet but that game
was also extremely sharp and we probably
didn't give this game enough justice
because of the other two games that were
very interesting but in this position
white is actually completely winning you
know white has two pieces for the rook
and also blacks King isn't
a very dangerous shape because of this
night on e6 and the White House you know
just a very dominant position so yeah we
although because of time pressure or
anything can still happen but of course
yeah this would you know this can go
either way but white is a big favorite
to win and in the meantime we have our
guest that's here fabric hey man thank
you very much for coming so
congratulations on a wonderful win
against the very strong player so how do
you feel about this game it was a very
complicated game I actually briefly just
checked on my phone the computer and the
friend I was never in trouble but during
the game it felt really difficult
because like I'm so underdeveloped even
though I'm up pawns it's not like my
pawns are going anywhere and my King
goes suspicious yeah so at what moment
did you feel like it was kind of the
most dangerous for you so first of all
how did you feel when he played this
should be five did he play this move
quickly or or was this did you feel like
this was preparation or over the board
inspiration it was in preparation
actually I saw this idea but I stopped
very quickly after when I played Queen
c7 I thought it should be five and I
thought I just take on h2 and go Queen
e5 and that's where I stopped and after
even there should be five I realized
that 97 there's some kind of meat yes I
saw that actually I miss queen g4 yeah
but you have 25 and maybe objectively
the best thing for him to do was to go
Queen e2 and because you can't really
play for winners yeah exactly but of
course yeah he was trying to be
ambitious in this game trying to play
interesting but now it looks like
actually you're kind of in control
because you're consolidating but I think
I have to find all this correct because
yeah there's so many nitrix
my queen goes through the wrong square
in night somewhere yeah H 5 H 4 was an
excellent idea because it gains a couple
of temples and it also helps get the
rope in the game so and most importantly
I move my queen
well at least I move my queen in a way
that I have checks and then that cannot
hit it yeah exactly yeah this was a nice
going wrong my initial idea was super 96
but there should be six okay yeah 25 in
and rook g2 and there is no way to stop
you know one of the mates so indeed the
this position was still you know very
dangerous for black from practical
standpoint of view and you know credit
to you for finding a lot of very very
precise moves 95 was an excellent move I
was still thinking yeah Queen a5 was a
very strong idea and then yeah white if
white takes of course it's winning for
black just up two points no more
initiative so white played here yeah and
here another excellent decision great
move here Bishop d7 because just
sacrificing the piece but basically
giving up material for some initiative
and now black is the one in control
yeah changes worst case scenario I have
three points now so even if you start
trading and this is kind of what
happened you know maybe yeah this should
be five was probably the best move
actually what were you thinking after
yeah no bishop c6 is a definitely a very
logical human more property for when
it's 3kg rotation six yes yeah basically
our move White has to give up the Queen
somehow yeah so this would have been
very very powerful but you know it's
it's a very hard move to find in Oh I
mean it's maybe not a hard move to find
but hard to see everything after that
and evaluate everything perfectly so
routine
or rocky 8 at least now white sort of
beat out the attack a little bit and
this is where white made the decisive
mistake so were you a little bit
surprised when you played Queen t3 or
because just objectively I don't know
the evaluation is but I think
practically it's kind of because ones
like first of all the flow of the game
changes to defend and right like I don't
know so if you would have tried to go 93
what was your idea here to try to play
for the initiative that before so rookie
for maybe a move like yeah but that
might be but let's say night before
trying to you know do trying to harass
the Queen a little bit because of this
year we're trading the bishop yeah he
gets whatever very important attacker
get some idea of going 95 and clean up
some carnage fire protection yeah
exactly well basically what you have to
realize is that the knight on c5 it
looks very good but it's actually not
doing anything really to impact the game
so he had to bring the to defense and
also to attack and this would still be
very much unclear I mean if rook h6
you know there's 95 Bishop b5 it's you
know you can block the rook now but
thankfully you know he played Queens e3
and now after queen up to now it's just
completely over for him there's actually
amazing ah no way to defend because
you're threatening rookie 3 and after
this rook e1 from there it's all she
wrote and white had to give up the Queen
I mean give up the piece because let's
say if Bishop a4 there's queen of two
and three things yeah and if Bishop b8
just for the spectators roof g6 Queen g1
and there's actually no way to defend
the mating attacks so this was pretty
much game over and and then he resigns
so very nicely done so how do you feel
about the rest of the tournament now
pretty good I started with three blocks
in the first four games but I have two
White's left and then we have one around
the day from now on
think it's going to be more pleasant so
yeah yeah I've seen you all your games
you've been playing some very
interesting chess in this tournament
very exciting chess in every game so
what you gave you the inspiration to
play in this kind of way in this
tournament I think I always played this
was just my opponents are giving me the
opportunity yesterday my game against
Brendan Jacobson was very complicated
unfortunately I think yeah that's that's
that's the important thing you know
sometimes it goes your way some that it
doesn't but you got to always keep the
positive mindset so a very good advice
to everybody listening and I wish you
best of luck continuing to playing good
and exciting chess at the same time just
like you did today
that's a lot for coming here thank you
alright with that said let's go back to
see what happened in the Joel banaba
game and here white actually won the
game
basically it was queen of three queen
bee to h5 rope Jade Queen III you know
think looking at some key squares here
rook e8 h6
rook f6 Bishop c5 rook up seven Bishop
h5 and black is now losing more material
here and his position also is kind of
deteriorating so this was a very nice
game for for Justin all right so let's
see if there any other games have been
finished so kasib Casa Corley got on the
board in the tournament
goddess first half a point against
Brandon Jacobson it was a very important
for Casa to kind of recover in this game
after a very difficult start but also
tough draw for Brandon because that
basically puts the end unfortunately for
his norm chances that's and actually and
as a matter of fact all of the all of
the games in the GM section are over in
both sections you know actually in both
sections games are actually over while
we're talking to the people you know
the games have actually finished so
Jackson buyuk one with white against
Bryan Escalante which puts him in the
lead with Dennis Porto's and Keaton as
we expected won the game and Aaron did
indeed convert his winning end game
against Eric Rosen and now we have a
chance to speak to Aaron himself Aaron
very nice game today how do you feel
about this game today yeah so what do
you think was the main thing that went
wrong for you in the previous games
probably just out of shape just really
poor form I was not getting any of my
prep in mm-hmm I was winding up in
positions I was unfamiliar with and it
kind of showed in the middle game plans
I was frequently just making bad
decisions yeah unfortunately that's just
part of share sometimes it happens in
length and that usually happens with me
too sometimes when you have a good
tournament all your crap happens to
happen having batteries likes kind of
compounds and then it's psychological -
it's hard but it's still you know it's
still very important you know trademark
over good chess player great fighter to
you know fight no matter what the
station is and you know you played I
think an excellent game here so what do
you think were some of the main critical
moments in this game against Erik so you
decided to play this Bishop d3 idea was
that was this preparation yeah this is
the first game I actually got my
preference this is an interesting idea I
guess I should take note myself because
sometimes I play the stuff of life yeah
I expected I think 96 96 yeah and this
would be two and night before yeah
something like that
I was trying to remember it leads to a
very interesting complex game I will not
make you give up your prayers
oh jeez fix is coming so probably should
be a dynamically equal now there are
maybe several ways to play beside
seafloor maybe it's something your key
one rookie one Bishop of one and then
fight forty-four right but yeah Bishop
d6 I wasn't expecting I almost thought
he might play e5 if I were also can he
go Bishop e7 because you know they
cannot take in this too dangerous and
then he's just trying to castle lady six
and Bishop of six and try to neutralize
this guy and I was gonna play Bishop d2
and d4 Bishop C two castles d4 that
makes a lot of sense and takes this kind
of misplaced yeah although it's possible
some of your pieces could also be
misplaced very very complex game anyway
yeah so he played there yeah I wanted to
play like 92 and he'll play to d4 you've
been good from deep for and it seems
kind of artificial for him but yeah I
mean if the center stays closed my I
might get attacked I wasn't sure I can't
take on g7 yeah yeah let's just for the
viewers if you take on g7 this [ __ ] goes
back on the night of four or even one
like it a lot of lines that I go Bishop
h6 here I don't think I survive or even
Queen f6 Knight c3 every night h4 yeah
so right which I did expect yeah maybe
if you should still Castle let's say you
play Knight c2 and then you know I can
play both like f6 six seven some kind of
seems like
equalist probably yeah but Knight c5
Bishop of 196 of 300 takes Queen g5 and
then T for K so if you if you Castle
what you still play d4 her I think so
yeah and then play Knight but takes
might be five and if he goes Bishop
before
Castle
yeah exactly yeah and the queen is not
on g5 work that shows a square so it's
actually not clear if probably Queen g5
was a little bit inaccurate because it
let you make it quicker probably should
capsule then you still have to find an a
useful to you
rook do you want yes and then maybe a
five though your wife is also 23 true
but this should be five let's say
tonight a can go to three and then these
six yeah believe it or not this is
actually very dangerous for you this
after takes Queen g5 there's just like
so good luckily for you good thing for
you he did not because this would have
been a more tougher decision but you
kind of committed themselves with this
Queen g5 okay which at least let you
yeah I was really happy when I get d5
and I thought he would take on d4 yeah
that was it was still possible but then
after this you know 64 ins and I didn't
yeah it still probably fine double edge
the five but yeah feeling up at least up
to d5 it looks like you have a practical
advantage yeah but you played have five
stuff and it seems kind of unclear still
I wasn't sure if I'm really better or
not
yeah even this was very unclear yes yeah
I was kind of second-guessing Queen C 3
because I make mine I go back to a yeah
I mean but it's a very complicated
position this this kind of game of
course it's good sound like a very
deeply yeah but yeah he and he was
saying maybe instead of Bishop e5 you
could play f55 right away maybe it was
better yes yeah three probably just very
bad right I didn't like that too much
yeah but maybe I take a five rope takes
and then C 1 this is P 1 or Bishop you
to the toolkit rookie f8 you can
sacrifice
it's different it's too much so f-five
was definitely very critical even here
so it's food black was always gonna get
a lot of play here but he played there
which traded off this kind of active
bishop maybe now you have less to worry
about in terms of the time I can play
for now at least you can kind of
stabilize things still I think you know
after move like e5 maybe it's not so bad
takes Queen g5 mm-hmm still maybe
yeah e6 and then takes Bishop c8
apparently yeah you cannot take this so
you have to go back let's say there is
still some compensation yeah yeah
because the knight on a3 is that there's
always compensation but he played it
this is a mistake I think because this
actually lets your knight become again
very relevant and even in this position
their apparel is still some kind of
bought okay it's already not so easy to
evaluate and he played there once you
got this then you're like in very good
shape because all your pieces are in you
get the t5 Square and from this point on
your one very smoothly yeah very
uncomfortable and from this point on I
mean definitely he could have defended
better but from this point on you he won
in a very smooth way you know one of the
last point here was I think you should
play the other okay after Queen takes d6
yes what he did I think just lets me
have a safe extra pawn but yeah that
move I was more worried about Queen be a
king age 7 or which King age 7 I guess
row t8 yeah like it's mate okay well
maybe you mean you could try that but
yeah apparently it's just mating attack
or Queen gets trapped or some kind of an
idea
yeah looks like enough yeah after Queen
these three I think
Oh Queen a try Queen f7 yes this one is
kind of as I always teach my students
you know rook porn up in a rock n game
when you have more active rook it's
usually just that lost and this was a
smart decision trading of the rooks yeah
and from this point on it was just
simple technique activating the king
winning the second point third and I
mean Eric was probably still having
hopes because of his game against
Rochelle but of course this is three
points yeah three points is a bit too
much and you know I almost so very nice
job Aaron a nice game you know so
finally things are turning around for
you so I wish you best of luck to try to
salvage this tournament and then there's
your best of luck in your career and you
know on your quest to you know getting
your 2,400 and improving your level and
hopefully you know getting the getting
the goal in the long run thanks thanks
for thanks for coming all right so with
that said let's take a look at some
other games that have just finished we
see Chico out there was able to win the
game against Pierre and genitals and
here we could see how these pawns
they are very intimidating indeed and
you know white has nothing better than
to resign because of unstoppable mating
threats
I always thought black was doing well I
mean here maybe white was having some
chances but once you know we got this
endgame black was kind of always in a
lot of control and let's take a look
again at Keaton's games see how that
game wrapped up so we left left off last
time somewhere around here and as I
expected this would be a very easy
conversion for Keaton from this position
and indeed it turned out to be so
and now black resigned because of an
unstoppable mating idea and here we have
our guests Keaton are you doing doing
well thank you thanks for thanks for
coming you know I meant to come earlier
but I keep forgetting about you here in
the basement
so yeah Varvara told me to make sure if
I want I should come talk to you so I
remember this time yeah so first of all
very nice game right here so and I was
very happy to see the opening because
this night of 3:3 I've played it many
times okay see this doing well yeah that
was my idea was if he played d5 to play
III I actually thought he would play
Knight f6 I move one and I had something
cooked up but maybe we'll save that for
another game yeah yeah and I've you know
I've played in this mover as well but
let's not reveal it so we're not gonna
talk too much about the opening because
you probably don't want to give well it
was a very flexible opening I mean both
sides had a lot of options now was this
should be to a still preparation because
I normally have played with Knight c3
disposition
I know Bishop e2 was in preparation I
just decided over the board to play it I
wasn't sure if I should play that
they're nice c3 or d4 and Bishop d3 but
I in the end I kind of felt like this
was the most flexible and the most
comfortable possibly yeah I played it on
I think in one game this kind of system
I think in this case black should
probably try to play more principled
with c5 96 right right away and then if
c5 then I'm probably gonna Castle and
then play for to take on d5 and play d4
and create some kind of point yeah
exactly yeah that's that would be
probably comfortable for white at least
yeah or maybe another system is just to
play b6
yes I'll spit should be seven I consider
that too but then you probably go Knight
c3 but should be seven yeah oh then you
can take on d5 man right I'm not sure
which way black I'll take back sometimes
it takes with the pawn sometimes of this
so basic a very rich position you know
why can play many different ways so if
you're looking for something interesting
there's a certainly line for you well
anyway in the game where did you think
it started going wrong for for block
well I'm not exactly sure but I had
decided if he played
be six that I was gonna go for it with
g4 because b6 is perfectly set up to
play against all of whites other plans
if Y you just castles and just to like
take on d5 and play d4 then black has
the perfect setup with the hanging pawns
with his night on d7 965 um I just
thought black would be very comfortable
so I thought if I want to organize any
problem for him I have to play g4 yeah
absolutely yeah it's a very principled
way to play I've played like this a few
times myself
I think I've seen some of your games and
all I couldn't remember off the top of
my head how their web I definitely seen
you play this before so yeah inspired
it's definitely oh I'm very happy but
definitely the very double edge so this
should be seven g5 maybe 94 was old I
was expecting 94 and then I wasn't
exactly sure how I was gonna play if I
was gonna trade a bunch of stuff and
play Queen c3 or I had some weird idea
95 to try to play d3 but I don't really
believe in this idea yep maybe rook
Jiwon is also pretty rook Jiwon is yell
so I was considering yeah but yeah 98
maybe it's no surprise 98 I figured he
must have seen something with 94 that he
didn't like because 94 is one of those
moves where everything has to go right
for him for it to work yeah exactly has
to be very careful and for you your
moves are easier you go for an attack
and let him figure out how to I got a
very large time advantage however that
didn't seem to bother him too much he
always very adept at playing quickly
this is actually my first time playing
him but he typically gets into time
pressure but you know 97 yeah this was
the moment where I think thinks there's
things started going south for him I
think this whole concept of 97 b5 is
just too slow and so the key should have
played four because I wasn't sure who it
should be his place I think I move like
rook c8 might have been possible and
then what would you still play bridge
for yeah so like let's say he plays a
move like even d4 interesting okay
suppose it takes takes takes Bishop g2
Lanisha Paige to let's say okay well
very interesting yeah I mean now that
I'm looking at it like if he plays d4
straight away what what happens I guess
takes takes a good point
well even if you take ya parently if you
take it's like it's better to almost
like have the 4 and H for not make
because yeah anyway very complex
position I mean there's also planned
there should be 796 that I was thinking
about Park tonight on a5 that makes all
the sense but 97 was played h4 v5 yeah
it was an interesting plan it was but I
thought it shouldn't be quite sound
because usually positional sacrifices as
a as a I've explained in the commentary
usually they work when your pieces are
better quality but in this position I
don't think blacks pieces are better
quality than whites make sense that's
why the sacrifice and Plus you know
gambits with black typically it's a
little bit worse position I mean if you
look at the game Carlson against MDL at
that last strong game there also it was
kind of MVL went for sacrifice similar
to that and it never worked because you
know Carlson had good pieces right there
was never but yea h5 was a very nice
plan yeah I need an age Foursquare yeah
definitely and here it looks like you
should be dominating felt like it if or
was very nice idea although maybe there
was other ways to play as well but you
for certain every additionally it made
sense I do wonder though what was your
plan if he would have played c4 right
here that's a nice color maybe five take
on g5 and then take on b3
oh yeah and after Queen takes you're
getting hit with nice d5 yeah yeah so e4
now that's why maybe four is not so good
because she does have c4 first right so
that's why maybe move like a four first
and if she order you just you just take
so maybe it's actually you know it's
it's it's one of these counterintuitive
examples but maybe playing you for right
away wasn't the best but it's of course
we have to find out - yeah and he
definitely had to try c4 yeah here he
was already in pretty big time pressure
yeah so this point practical play comes
into a place more than objective and
evaluation but no I mean I had seen c4
only in passing
I didn't really see the whole idea it's
really quite dangerous yeah yeah could
have been yeah but you know the way you
played you always kind of kept the game
under control
no here was a critical moment I really
wanted to just take once and somehow
keep my bishop on c4 against his knight
but I just could not find a way to do
that favor
what if you Castle I thought about that
what I didn't like was Nate before 94
Quinn of five and then simply Knight
takes a two with the idea of night
before and playing for Queen a5 as well
and also takes deep yeah and this actual
does low dangerous but it does look like
after relation and rook h6 it does look
like your attack does come first okay
because if he goes there you actually
could just take the rook is hanging so
that's also inconvenient for you it does
turn out that you are actually winning
but again and the practical gear just
didn't connect all these dots yeah it's
not easy I was looking for stuff like
this
but it didn't yeah intuitively I really
wanted to keep my Bishop yeah yeah
exactly that would have been best
positionally but you know there's only a
small advantage yeah you only have a
small advantage but you know small but
stable and still easier for you to play
and of course he's on time pressure so
right yeah here it looks like you know
rook F 3 was probably a mistake because
rooks you three you want to play anyway
right although his idea of trading in e4
was quite interesting that got the
position very complicated but I do want
to show you one beautiful variation I
saw I'm curious whether you saw I didn't
really watch this game as much live
unfortunately there's so many
interesting games I was full of course
yeah go ahead
okay so the way the game continued then
with okay f3 and trading in e4 so it
seems like I probably have to play d4
well there's also some Queen c4 a move I
don't know how because the work if he
takes the phone well he takes what the
rook you take this trip g700 Queen f7
okay and you'll see this was a key idea
and if you do you do retakes beautiful
line yeah so Queen c4 was actually a bit
better I wish I'd seen that that would
have been like okay thief was they I
actually did see the idea and
context so see before we three I mean
yeah and then Queenie for yeah so I
thought the critical move here was
rookies room d7 mm-hmm and my idea here
was to play d5 and after rookie seven I
saw I could play Queen f5 and then after
he to rook e1 Bishop d2 then I have to
with this idea I did see it in this
position right it's not in conjunction
with Queen c4 yes yeah very beautiful
yeah just to show the whole variations
for the fans
beautiful mate so yeah in the game he
took 24 so yeah now I thought I was just
winning just winning yeah yeah yeah
Queen g7 he made it move with one second
he made a lot of moves with one second
yeah it's just too many problems so
you're just taking yeah there's just
nothing he can do and yeah from this
point on it was smooth conversions so
very nice fighting game and it looks
like you were never really in in trouble
and even though of course in such a game
you know inaccuracies and even mistakes
are expected but I think overall you
know you played a very nice game thank
you and general it was so far this
tournament is going very very well for
you so what's the main thing that's
working well for you in this tournament
well I you know the first three games
were pretty tough I just barely beat
Taurus and I really back and forth now
this game becomes very critical because
if you hadn't beaten he would have been
like running away with the tournament
potentially I know he played amazing
after then he played well against me -
it was just a very close hard-fought
game that was just kind of lucky to win
at the end and then Aaron Jacobsen
played a great game against me he really
outplayed me with black and there was a
long tough game and then so I lost that
one and then Aaron grabbed minsky was
out playing me too and it looked like he
was gonna convert an end game with white
but I just barely hung on and got a draw
but then yesterday
I really came ready to battle I knew my
game with Rochelle was gonna be very
tough she hadn't lost a game yet but I
was able to get a position that I felt
comfortable with and I kind of went back
to my roots a little bit playing the
trombone ski I hadn't played it in some
time but right I thought it would be a
good surprise for that game worked out
very well it was a Unbounce game and you
know it was a type of game you were much
more comfortable than your opponent for
sure yeah and then my game with Peter
last night was a real mess
he offered me drawn some moment or I
just wasn't sure at all what was going
on but it was really just too fun of a
position to call the day so we held it
out and that one went my way and then
yes--that's goes to show that whoever
doesn't risk doesn't drink champagne so
whoever fights usually will get good
results at some moments so I wish you
the best of luck going forward best of
fighting chess and looking forward to
seeing your next few games thank you
very much Alex thanks a lot for coming
all right so let's see what let's wrap
up quickly on what other games have
finished which games we haven't looked
at yet Casa Corley Brandon was a draw
Joel we against Justin we did take a
look at we didn't take a look at the
whole game but basically was a pretty
complex real opus where it looks like a
white kind of black went for an
unbalanced game it's a very fighting
position chances for both sides but
looks like somewhere deep into time
pressure black made few inaccuracies
white sakura's the exchange really kind
of gone well in soccer was the beet soup
one it looked like black was doing well
here but somewhere something went wrong
I mean maybe this should be seven was
never getting the last piece in the game
and putting pressure here after Oh Jade
Queen h5 maybe Queen h5 was missed by
Joel because after this point being
Bishop of six intermediate and suddenly
after this white is having a lot of
initiative and
you know black was kind of lost track a
little but with this kind of game and
eventually in the highly dynamic
position
wideout played black and also Jack's
game we haven't really looked at Jack
won a big game against Escalante with
white which brings them to the lead
shared lead with Dennis Boros was also
very sharp game Kings Indian which we
didn't give another justice to and it
did look like white got a good opening
all his pieces are kind of playing
blacks pieces are kind of on the back
rank and eventually you know the bishop
on see it's kind of a problem for
blackened eventually White's got 34
square ends up from there only a white
kind of one relatively smoothly won the
poem and although black did find a way
to get counter played in this position
so the game was still up and there in
fact in this position you know still
anyone's game after move like Knight xh2
because after this you know reflects d14
so III but he three looks like it was a
mistake
looks like black missed some details
perhaps he missed that after this rookie
eight Bishop f8 there's just Queen text
e4 I mean he must have missed some
detail and then black-white was just
able to sacrifice back to material
transposing into the winning Queen
endgame which white was able to convert
without so much trouble in this field we
took a look at Keaton's game against
Valerie we analyzed it quite deeply with
Keaton we didn't really get a chance to
take a look at Tauruses beautiful win
against Aaron Jacobsen which was
actually the big game of the round
because they were both leading the
tournament absolutely and now Torres is
is tied up with Kira at the top and this
was a game which started with a very
quiet nimzo-indian but it turned into
you know very dangerous initiative for
white and I always thought black is
relatively comfortable here I know that
I think there's also Quint xt5 but
basically this is supposed to be a very
solid line for black
but it looks like Taurus was able to
create some little mosquito bite
problems for example he wants to get the
to bishops because if he takes then
there's some idea like takes takes takes
and blacks king is a bit weak here
so black decided to play rook e8 maybe
it was better to play move like g6 and
trading off the bishop or even just
going back to should be seven
but either way there are some
uncomfortability so definitely white
showed some very good preparation and
now already after Queen of three and a
beautiful sacrifice here white actually
ended up you know with a very nice
attack and from this point on tours
conducted the attack in an absolutely
brilliant fashion this could easily end
up being a game of the tournament
potentially there's no other you know
big fireworks awfully they got some
extra money for that you know yeah
that's true it and here black resigned
because it's gonna be made with Queen
and Bishop in many different ways well
and now Jacobson has to lick his wounds
because there's still one more round at
five o'clock and he will be going up
against here in grab in ski yeah and who
won his first game yeah so both players
are kind of wounded because Erin just
lost a very key game you know but now he
needs to just forget about what happens
completely rear completely just forget
about everything that happened earlier
in the tournament and just focus in the
Una's next game where he's gonna get a
chance to player and grab in ski and
she'll probably be white and he'll have
a chance to you know
oh I mean Aaron just won a very big game
but of course as he's mentioned he's a
little bit off forms so this is Aaron's
chance to get back in a tournament and
but it's also Aaron's chance to
potentially Aaron Grove in skis chance
it's to Aaron's playing so I it's Aaron
Rubin skis chance to get back in the
tournament
as well because obviously Aaron Jacobson
is a little bit wounded so we'll see
what will happen between kind of to
Aaron's very interesting battle if we
have standings I'd like to
take a look at it because there's some
interesting things we can gather first
of all the Grand Master norm section one
of our story lines is almost completely
passed away as in this division we have
only two players who can norm and his
toxic abrahama and justin wang he is the
number seven you 14 under 14 player in
the entire world and he's had success
here before but three straight that's
gonna be a tough challenge for either
one of these players and in fact
impossible for both because both of them
will be playing each other that is wing
and Abraham Ian will be playing each
other in just about an hour you can see
it at us chess champs calm and that will
knock at least one of them out of
contention mathematically for a
grandmaster norm thoughts on this field
so far Alex yeah well I mean though the
games are incredibly fighting spirit but
the GMs are still showing why there are
GM's why they're gatekeepers and why
they still want to make it not easy for
the norm seekers because they you know
they've you know really battled I'm sure
to get these norms to get the GM title
so now they want to make sure that their
opponents also have to battle and the
price the prices here are not bad and
they definitely give a lot of incentive
for the GM's to really play for the
maximum and fight in every single game
and it's gonna be a very intriguing
battle it's when Dennis and and Jack in
who will prevail and of course it's
still there's a fill an outside
possibility that players like Justin
Wang and the TF and even players like
Andrew Brandon and Joe can you know
really if they win three straight even
they can still potentially come back and
you know make a run take a round to that
first place prize yeah let's look at our
IM norm standings after six rounds have
been played here there's only one player
who can still get an IM norm and that is
vita master aaron jacobson and hey look
i mean you don't win three straight he's
still in the running for the top prize
as we've said and look at all these ties
everybody is so close no one's really
run
away which shifts the balance away from
the norm aspect of the tournament into
we might be looking at playoffs at the
end of this thing Alex very well
possibly yeah and once again the IMS are
dominating they're shown like kind of
who is boss they're playing very good
enterprise and chefs we've just seen
Heaton and Taurus when you know very
nice games at a critical moment against
people who you know we're really needing
the win you know right both Aaron and
Aaron Jacobson and guru run car
respectively we're both really needing
wins or at least you know trying to
stave off initiative with black and
maybe come back and win with white and
they both kind of went down in flames in
a way so this just goes to show that the
IMS are there there there I am for a
reason and they're gonna make it tough
and you know it's pretty clear that
determined that everybody can really
learn a lot from and hopefully this
experience that the people who didn't
get the norm will help them to be able
to get the norms sooner rather than
later in the next tournaments before we
sign off we'd like to remind you that
tonight at us chest champs calm 5 p.m.
Central Time you can see round 7 it's
our last double day after all here at
the norm Congress and I'd like to show
you the standing are the pairings rather
for what you could see later on tonight
and really the key matchups touched on
it before but right here in the middle
talked about Bohemian and Justin way the
two norm seekers that are left here in
the GM section we will see it either one
of them can prevail if it's a draw
well hey will you tie you think that you
know in this game probably both players
will try to really play hard for a win
so but you know it will finding things
is what often happens games like this
still sometimes ended in draws but let's
hope that one of them wins and still has
the chance so that there's some intrigue
going into the last two days yeah and
also another intriguing matchup Joe
Benaiah and Jackson in Puglia and hey
Brandon Jacobson and - Boros that should
be a good one because Brandon can now
play spoiler and Brandon still one store
right the ship in his tournament he
still has three points which is not all
that bad and if you
when last few games he won't get a norm
but he can still tie for first and he
can still try to gain some rating and
get valuable experience and finally in
our I am norm section tonight at us
chest champs calm let's follow the story
of the Aaron's Aaron Jacobson and Aaron
Burr Ben ski will Aaron Jacobson walk
away with a full point and also a key
matchups from here on out anything with
Luis Torres Rochelle Wu and Luis Torres
a possible spoiler situation as well
again possible yes but I think more
interesting would be besides the Aaron
battle would be candid shoe karate
against Keaton because Kenta is
obviously the highest rated player here
is a young player who can it's kind of
similar as the Brendan Jacobsen against
Dennis water situation where Brandon is
maybe not having the best term he's
hoping but he's capable of beating
anyone same thing would she karate I
think he's the kind of player who can
lose to anyone and beat anyone and in
that regards and and Keaton will be
black so let's see if Kent will you know
play spoilers role and you know also
writers ship in the in the terms you can
catch us tomorrow at 2 p.m. for the
penultimate round of the st. Louis norm
Congress it'll be round 8 by then and a
lot more will be cleared up because like
I said 5 p.m. just about an hour and a
half away here in st. Louis will be
having around 7:00 and so tomorrow is
round 8 Tuesday is around 9 and playoffs
if necessary so thank you for joining us
here at us chest champs calm and in the
YouTube chat we really enjoyed having
you this was produced by the world's
greatest production B team Gainey
Machuca is the technical director Isaac
Krantz his graphics and audio the show
was designed by Eric Mosel Tammy height
is the streamer this right here he is
the hardest-working man in chess
grandmaster Alec Slenderman did
interviews back back to back to back
thank you it's been a pleasure as always
el no problem it's a pleasure working
with you as well and yeah it's um it's
been an exciting day today and you know
that I think the analysis that the
players gave were X
and I'm sure you guys can really learn a
lot from not just me but also the
players thoughts and the variations they
were giving and now we can see why there
are such strong players the lines that
they were seeing you know just like it's
one thing to look at the game at home
with let's say chess WOM with the
computer and just sitting in your couch
it's another thing to sitting there and
battling and you can understand why
they're gonna be you know some mistakes
because it's very difficult to see
absolutely everything yeah right so it's
no doubt the interviews are invaluable
it's amazing my name is Ben Simon until
tomorrow at 2 p.m. Central at u.s. chess
champs calm we say so long from the Show
Me State
[Music]
[Music]
you